Cameron is in California hi Cameron
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
so my wife and I have been following a
plan for about three years
we're on baby steps four five and six
this year we bought a house we committed
getting extra on our tithe to support
our church through a giving initiative
and then we got pregnant with our first
child yeah and yeah yeah and then her
employer notified her that they've been
overpaying her for the last three years
and they're demanding repayment of
$30,000 so we're trying to figure out
how do we handle this and do we you know
do a repayment plan do we pay down a
lump sum do we treat it like it's a debt
snowball situation okay um what does she
make a year she makes she gross is about
68,000 and they were overpaying her but
ten thousand dollars a year and you
didn't notice yeah because she gets like
mileage reimbursements with every
paycheck and she gets it on direct
deposit and so we don't ever really look
at the pay stubs and through their own
mistakes they they put a payment in that
was listed one time and then ended up
being recurring and yeah a lot of crazy
things were happening because their
paycheck at the beginning of her
employment yeah but I I guess my
question part of my question is the for
three years you've been receiving an
extra $800 a month and you weren't
keeping up with your budget enough to
notice that well it wasn't that much
more like for fifteen months but again
we weren't really focusing about fifty a
month is not there is not $30,000 and
three years okay they've calculated it
all out and that's what they told us so
okay 800 a month is ten thousand a year
times three is thirty thousand
okay yeah we looked over the numbers and
it is around 30,000 so did you receive
too much every month or in lump sum yeah
you know there was an every month they
made a mistake with her retirement and
had to reimburse her for something and
was supposed to be a one-time payment
added to her check and then it was made
recurring and just came with every check
well I would just it's absurd for them
to make the mistake and then require you
to pay it in a lump sum so they're not
acquiring a lump sum they are requiring
repayment though okay coming out of her
check for how many years three years
they've offered they you know they're
flexible on it they're saying you could
do five years two years ten years it
sounds like it's kind of up to us and
that's why I want to know what the best
would be to do and we make a lump sum
payment and then put it on a yearly plan
or do we throw as much at it as possible
as we can they can do some stuff with
taxes to where some of it gets taken out
pre taxes so then the overall amount
that we have to pay back is less but I
still don't know if we should try and
stretch this out so with the minimal hit
on our monthly income or we'd knock it
out as quick as possible to get it out
of our lives how like likely if she stay
in this job she's really enjoys working
for County and she's really good at it
and you know obviously things can change
we'll start having kids but I think
right now her plan is to keep working
yeah I would put it on about a two or
three year thing just coming out of her
trick I would put it on a two or three
year thing just coming out of her check
okay but you guys got to get on top of
your stuff better yeah we did track her
income but you know we're tracking it
based off of the checks that she was
cashing and figure income off of that no
no but I mean you're looking you should
be able to look and when you did your
taxes and go we got $10,000 more than we
should have you need to be on top of
your stuff better
this and even in this conversation you
thought it was 450 and when it's got to
be 850 and you still don't know and
while I'm talking to you on the crap
this got to 3 at $30,000 other than we
went through the numbers but you don't
know the numbers so you're you're
warning there is that this happens
I mean it's happened here I've as an
employer I have overpaid people I've
never requested they repay it I figure
if we're that stupid we lost the money
so we've even we overpay we just let
them keep it but we're not the county
government so they don't have the
flexibility I've got but but your job is
to be more on top of your stuff than
this to know what's going on with your
money in more detail than this you want
to be completely nerded out but I mean
when when you make six sixty seventy
thousand dollars a year and you get an
extra ten thousand dollars that's
noticeable this isn't an extra thousand
dollars and where you might go I didn't
know it was being here with withheld on
the taxes I can't tell that close and
that kind of thing but um I mean you
guys just got a look at your pay stubs
and stuff you know so anyway yeah you're
gonna be repaying it you're legally
liable to and I would do it over the
next two to three years because with a
baby on the way I don't know how much
longer she's gonna work and I do not
want you to get in the situation where
she doesn't work there anymore because
but she feels like she has to because
this is still hanging over her head